Nichts, kein einziger Gesang!
* Er pfeift. *
Keine Antwort mehr.
Hören Sie was?
Man hört nur Schweigen,
sonst nichts.
Eine Amsel im Wald da drüben.
Hier weiter rechts
war früher die Feldlerche, ganz nah.
Und auf dieser Seite
haben wir ein Maisfeld, völlig tot.
Es fehlen die Kräuter.
Der Boden ist kaum bewachsen.
Hier hat die Lerche früher gesungen,
auch dort und weiter entfernt.
Allein in diesem Umkreis
gab es vier oder fünf Sänger.
Wir nennen das
Feldlerchen-Territorien.
Der Eindruck täuscht:
Die Landschaft
ist ja immer noch grün,
aber das ist nicht dasselbe Grün
wie vor 60 oder 70 Jahren.
Ein sehr nettes Grün, aber
fast unbrauchbar für die Tierwelt.
Georges Gillieron
ist ein wandelndes Vogellexikon.
Der passionierte Hobbyornithologe
war früher Lehrer.
Auf diesen Feldern
in der Nähe von Villeneuve
begann er als 15-Jähriger damit,
Vögel zu zählen.
Nehmen wir mal den 10. Mai 1953,
als ich hier mit meinen ersten
Beobachtungen begann.
Gartenrotschwanz: mehrere.
Oder hier: Feldschwirl, ein Vogel,
den es in dieser Gegend
schon viele Jahre nicht mehr gibt.
Ich schrieb noch vorsichtig:
"mehrere".
Dann der Drosselrohrsänger,
der Grösste aus der Familie
der Grasmücken: viele.
Teichrohrsänger: viele.
Mönchsgrasmücke: viele.
Dorngrasmücke: viele. Die ist von
dieser Ebene völlig verschwunden.
Alles in diesem Stil.
Ich bewegte mich in einem
sehr kleinen Umkreis und konnte so
die kleinräumige Entwicklung der
Vogelarten sehr genau mitverfolgen.
Die selteneren Arten,
die spezielle Lebensräume brauchen,
werden überall verschwinden.
Wir müssen uns entscheiden:
Entweder überleben bestimmte Tiere,
oder es bleibt bald
nur noch der Mensch auf der Erde.
45 % aller Feldvogelarten
sind heute gefährdet.
Es sind genau die Vogelarten,
die einst im Schweizer Mittelland
weit verbreitet waren.
Francois Turrian
erkennt jeden Vogel an seinem Gesang.
Jahr für Jahr beteiligt er sich
an der Zählung
der Schweizerischen Vogelwarte.
Sein Revier beginnt
in diesem kleinen Wald bei Yverdon.
Was hören Sie da?
Einen Zaunkönig. Den hört man gut.
Sein Gesang ist sehr klangvoll.
Ein interessanter Vogel. Er ist
polygam und baut mehrere Nester.
Die Weibchen wählen eines aus.
Die Waldvogelbestände
sind eher stabil.
Ich habe hier
keine markante Abnahme bemerkt.
Im Gegensatz zu den Vögeln
in Landwirtschaftsgebieten.
Und da ist auch ein Buchfink
in diesen Tannen.
Der häufigste Vogel der Schweiz.
Glauben wir Laien,
dass alles in Ordnung ist, weil wir
immer noch den Buchfinken hören?
In gewissem Sinne schon.
Die Vögel um uns herum sind die,
die am häufigsten vorkommen.
Buchfinken, Kohlmeisen usw.
sieht man noch oft,
v.a. im Garten und im Wald.
Aber der Eindruck täuscht, viele
andere Arten sind am Verschwinden.
Hier gibt es keine Vögel mehr.
Seit 10 Min. habe ich
noch keinen einzigen gehört.
Am Waldrand
gab es früher immer welche.
Hier im Landwirtschaftsgebiet
suche ich sie vergeblich.
Francois Turrian
geht strikt nach Protokoll vor.
An drei Tagen während
der Fortpflanzungszeit im Frühling
dreht er seine Runden:
immer zur selben Zeit
auf einer Fläche von 1 km2.
Eigentlich ist das hier eine Wüste.
Ich konnte mir gerade mal
eine vorbeifliegende Krähe notieren.
Früher gab es hier
25 Territorien von Lerchen.
Letztes Jahr waren es nur noch 14.
Die Zählung
besteht weitgehend darin,
dass man die Vögel hört
und ihren Gesang erfasst.
Der Gesang markiert das Territorium
eines Vogelpaars,
in welchem es seine Jungen aufzieht.
Ich sehe den unaufhaltsamen
Niedergang verschiedener Vogelarten,
die meine Jugend prägten.
Das ist sehr traurig.
In der ganzen Schweiz erheben
Hunderte Freiwillige Daten
für die Schweizerische Vogelwarte
Sempach in der Nähe von Luzern.
In den letzten Jahren wurden
besonders viele Daten erhoben.
Für die dritte Ausgabe
des Schweizer Brutvogelatlas.
Dieser Atlas hält seit 60 Jahren
die Entwicklung der Vogelwelt fest.
Verantwortlich
ist Biologe Lukas Jenni
von der Schweizerischen Vogelwarte.
Für den Brutvogelatlas
sind über 2'300 Flächen
in der Schweiz untersucht worden
anstelle der üblichen 320.
Das gibt einen sehr guten Überblick
über die Verbreitung und Dichte
der Vögel, je nach Landesteil.
Und auch über die Anzahlen.
Und natürlich über die Entwicklung
seit den 70er-, 90er-Jahren
bis jetzt.
Hier sehen wir die Abnahme in rot,
die Zunahme in grün.
V.a. eben die Abnahme in rot
von 35 Vogelarten,
die auf das Landwirtschaftsgebiet
als Lebensraum angewiesen sind.
Wir sehen, dass es nur ganz wenige
grüne Flecken gibt,
wie z.B. die Champagne Genevoise.
Wir sehen, dass im Mittelland
in grossen Teilen
nicht viel passiert ist,
weil dort diese Vogelarten
schon verschwunden sind.
Die Vögel, die in den Kulturen
selber ihre Nester anlegen
und die Nahrung suchen,
denen geht es sehr schlecht.
Für gewisse Arten wie z.B. die
Feldlerche oder das Braunkehlchen
ist die Abnahme der Individuen
40, 50, 60 %.
Das ist also massiv?
- Es ist sehr massiv.
Ist es beunruhigend?
Es spiegelt natürlich wider,
wie wir mit der Umwelt umgehen,
wie die Landwirtschaft
intensiviert worden ist.
Insofern ist es
ein sehr beunruhigendes Phänomen.
Ein eindrückliches Beispiel
für den Einfluss der Landwirtschaft
ist die Orbe-Ebene.
Wir sind hier etwa
auf 600 m ü.M.
Es gibt zwar
noch schöne Blumenwiesen,
aber schlicht keine Vögel mehr.
Man hört noch ein paar Grillen,
einige Insekten,
aber die Vögel können nicht nisten,
weil früher gemäht wird.
Der Berufsornithologe Lionel Maumary
kämpft seit Langem
für den Lebensraum bestimmter Arten
wie dem Wachtelkönig,
der akut vom Aussterben bedroht ist.
Die meisten Männchen,
die ich gefangen habe,
hatten Verstümmelungen,
ziemlich sicher von Mähdreschern.
Und die Weibchen
werden gleich im Nest getötet.
Wiesenvögel nisten am Boden.
Das ist das grosse Problem.
Die Nester sind also
den landwirtschaftlichen Maschinen
völlig schutzlos ausgesetzt
und werden immer wieder zerstört.
Ich finde die Lage dramatisch.
Deswegen reise ich
auch so oft es geht ins Ausland,
um Vögel zu beobachten.
In der Schweiz ist es schlicht
zu deprimierend, v.a. im Mittelland.
Ich spreche nicht von den Bergen,
wo es noch Vielfalt gibt,
aber im Mittelland ist es für einen
Ornithologen niederschmetternd.
Wie grosse Teile des Mittellandes
ist die Orbe-Ebene durch Menschenhand
stark verändert worden.
Vor 150 Jahren war hier
noch ein riesiges Sumpfgebiet.
Um das Land nutzbar zu machen,
wurden Flüsse kanalisiert,
Sümpfe trockengelegt
und Parzellen zusammengelegt.
Der Mensch
ging derart effizient zur Sache,
dass in der Schweiz über 90 %
der Sumpfgebiete verschwanden.
Heute herrscht intensive
Landwirtschaft vor -
auf solchen Feldern
finden Vögel keinen Lebensraum mehr.
* Verspielte Klaviermusik *
Es ist
ein drastisches Beispiel dafür,
wie der Mensch sich die Natur
zum Untertan macht.
Jeder Quadratmeter
wird bewirtschaftet.
Klar, bei unserer Bevölkerungsdichte
ist der Druck auf die Landschaft
sehr hoch.
Dazu kommen
die bekannten Schweizer Tugenden:
Wir sind fleissig
und leisten ganze Arbeit.
So hat die Natur
einfach überhaupt keinen Platz mehr.
Das Resultat:
In den Landwirtschaftszonen
ist fast jede zweite Art bedroht
oder bereits ausgestorben,
weil geeigneter Lebensraum
zur Fortpflanzung fehlt.
Die Vogelarten, die noch da sind,
sind etwas weniger anspruchsvoll.
Sie begnügen sich
mit ein paar Hecken am Feldrand.
Um sie mit der Kamera einzufangen,
waren wir
auf die guten Augen und Ohren
von Lionel Maumary angewiesen.
Mit der nötigen Geduld
haben wir sie gefunden - zwei.
Kommt, sie kommt näher, sie wird
sich genau da vorne hinsetzen!
Die Goldammer
ist ein etwas fauler Zugvogel,
der nur ein paar 100 km,
selten auch 1'000, zurücklegt.
Diese Vögel sind zum Teil sesshaft.
Einige bleiben also
das ganze Jahr über hier.
Und dann sehen wir einen Neuntöter.
Dieses Leichtgewicht
fliegt zum Überwintern
so weit
wie ein Langstreckenflugzeug,
mehr als 10'000 km,
manchmal bis nach Südafrika.
Neuntöter gab's viel mehr,
es ist nicht so lange her,
da waren sie überall.
Heute muss man sie wirklich suchen.
Sie spiessen ihre Beute wie Insekten
oder Käfer auf Stacheln auf,
damit sie
lang genug am Leben bleiben,
um dann
als Notproviant dienen zu können.
Das war jetzt gerade eine Wachtel.
Sie ist dort in der Hecke
gleich hinter uns.
Eine seltene Art?
Da sieht man halt, wie wichtig
Hecken für die Nahrungssuche sind.
Dort finden die Vögel
Insekten und Unterschlupf.
Einige Bauern richten auch mal
kleine Naturoasen ein,
aber davon gibt es nur wenige.
Die Vögel
verschwinden Schritt für Schritt,
doch weil sie
kaum noch jemand kennt,
fällt es der Allgemeinheit
nicht auf.
Wer kennt denn schon
das Braunkehlchen, die Bekassine,
den grossen Brachvogel
oder den Kiebitz?
Dass wir drei Arten Echte Würger
verloren haben,
wissen nur die Ornithologen.
Die Vögel verschwinden
vollkommen stillschweigend.
Naturschützer und Experten
schlagen mehr und mehr Alarm.
So auch Francois Turrian
in La Sauge am Neuenburgersee.
Der Ornithologe und Vogelzähler
ist Regionalleiter von Birdlife,
einer internationalen
Vogelschutzvereinigung.
Der Rückgang der Vogelarten
ist ein Alarmzeichen,
genau wie Fieber beim Menschen.
Ein Zeichen dafür, dass
im Organismus etwas schiefläuft,
das man ernst nehmen sollte.
Die Vögel sind
wie ein Thermometer unserer Umwelt.
Das ist das Gleiche.
Die Vögel verschwinden,
weil unsere Lebensart mit
ihrer Existenz nicht kompatibel ist.
In der Schweiz sind dreimal so viele
Vogelarten gefährdet wie weltweit.
Die Schweiz
setzt die Vögel unter Druck,
weil unsere Lebensart
nicht im Geringsten
mit ihrem nachhaltigen Schutz
vereinbar ist.
Laut Naturschützern wie ihm
ist unser Landwirtschaftsmodell
das Hauptproblem.
Dieses Modell
beruht auf Ertragssteigerung
und ist abhängig von Chemikalien.
Doch die Risiken von Düngemitteln
und Pestiziden für die Umwelt
sind eigentlich
seit über 50 Jahren bekannt.
Schon Anfang der 60er-Jahre
schlug eine amerikanische Biologin
mit ihrem Buch "Der stille Frühling"
Alarm.
(übersetzter Originalton)
Überall werden wahllos
Chemikalien versprüht, die nicht nur
wie gewünscht die schädlichen,
sondern auch
die nützlichen Insekten töten,
die die Vögel verstummen lassen
und die Fische
in unseren Gewässern töten.
All das nur, um ein paar Unkräuter
und Schädlinge loszuwerden.
Rachel Carson
rüttelt ganz Amerika auf,
indem sie die toxische Wirkung
von Pestiziden wie DDT
an den Pranger stellt.
Die Öffentlichkeit ist schockiert, da
DDT zunächst als Wundermittel galt.
DDT, eine Erfindung
des Basler Herstellers Geigy,
wurde weltweit im Kampf gegen Mücken,
Läuse, Maikäfer
und andere unerwünschte Insekten
eingesetzt.
Aber DDT ist viel gefährlicher,
als die Hersteller behaupten.
"Es war ein stummer Frühling."
"In der Morgendämmerung -
einst erfüllt durch den Klang
unzähliger Singvögel -
war nicht der geringste Gesang
mehr zu hören."
"Stille herrschte in den Feldern,
den Wäldern und den Sümpfen."
In seinen Ornithologievorlesungen
erinnert Francois Turrian
an die Lehren aus der Vergangenheit,
indem er Rachel Carson zitiert.
Ende der 50er-Jahre war Amerika
ein grosser DDT-Produzent -
dieses bekannte Pestizid,
das durch seine Giftigkeit
grossen Schaden anrichtet.
Es konzentriert sich
in der Nahrungskette.
Und die Vögel am Ende dieser
Nahrungskette waren die Opfer.
Die Welt beginnt zu erkennen,
dass Chemie
nicht nur Fortschritt bedeutet.
DDT wird ab den 70er-Jahren
in den meisten Ländern verboten.
Doch die Produktion neuer Pestizide
geht ungebremst weiter.
In den 90er-Jahren kommen
Neonikotinoide auf den Markt.
Das hochpotente Gift
ummantelt das Saatgut.
Die Pflanze nimmt es
während des Wachstums in sich auf
und wird so giftig für Insekten.
Besonders betroffen: die Bienen.
Wir verfolgen das seit Jahrzehnten
an den Honigbienen.
Es gibt Auswirkungen auf
die Fortpflanzung, aufs Immunsystem.
Immer mehr wird uns klar,
dass das, was für die Honigbienen
gut erforscht ist,
auch für andere Bereiche
im Ökosystem zutrifft.
Andere Lebewesen
wie Säugetiere, Vögel,
Reptilien oder Wasserlebewesen
zeigen ähnliche Symptome,
wenn sie in Kontakt
mit Neonikotinoiden kommen.
Eine sehr beunruhigende Entwicklung.
Alexandre Aebi erforscht die Wirkung
der Neonikotinoide
an der Universität Neuenburg.
Schon in kleinsten Mengen
sind sie enorm giftig.
Wenige Gramm wirken vermutlich
5-10'000-mal so stark wie DDT.
Ich habe das Buch
"Der Stille Frühling" gelesen.
Es war schlimm zu merken: Wir machen
wieder die gleichen Fehler.
Wir wissen, dass Neonikotinoide
für Vögel und Insekten
problematisch sind,
verwenden sie aber trotzdem weiter.
Es gibt zwar auch positive Schritte
wie Verbote bestimmter Substanzen,
aber wir sind weit davon entfernt,
diese Gruppe von Pestiziden
prinzipiell zu verbieten,
die auf das Nervensystem
der Insekten abzielt.
Seit diesem Jahr
sind drei dieser Neonikotinoide
in der Schweiz verboten.
Das Bundesamt für Umwelt
folgte damit einem Beschluss der EU.
Ein erster Schritt der Schweiz,
die im internationalen Vergleich
besonders viele Pestizide braucht.
Die Schwabs sind Landwirte
in fünfter Generation.
Kein Bio, aber hier werden
die Pflanzen präzise
und nur bei Bedarf
mit Chemie behandelt.
Auf einer Fläche von über 40 ha
im Berner Seeland.
An diesem Gerät kann man
die Dosierung einstellen.
Man kann so genauer spritzen.
Die Fahrgeschwindigkeit mit dem
Traktor wird immer kommuniziert,
sowie auch die Restmengen.
Sogar der Fahrweg
wird mir kommuniziert.
So ist
eine genaue Dosierung möglich.
Wir spritzen schon 20 % weniger
Chemie mit der neuen Technik.
Peter Schwab baut Kartoffeln
und verschiedene Gemüse
für den Grosshandel an.
Das Endprodukt muss top sein.
Sonst nehmen es
die Grossverteiler nicht?
Die Frage stellt sich schon,
wie es hergestellt wurde.
Aber wenn man das Produkt abliefert,
stellt sich die Frage in dem Moment
nicht. Dann muss es top sein.
Eine Fliege oder ein Fehler,
und die Lieferung geht retour.
Bald wird er den Betrieb
seinem Sohn Roger übergeben.
Dann gehen wir zu den Kiebitzen.
Ich hole Martin.
Dann gehen wir auf Feldkontrolle.
- Gut.
Bei uns war die Ausbildung
auf den landwirtschaftlichen Schulen
komplett produktionsausgerichtet.
Komplett. Produktion mit Chemie,
immer grösser und immer schneller.
Heute wird das hinterfragt.
In der Betriebsleiterschule
wurde meinem Sohn beigebracht,
Ökologie mit intensiver
Landwirtschaft zu verbinden.
Das ist ein neuer Ansatz,
und das ist richtig so.
Es ist kein Trend,
es  m u s s  sein.
Das wissen wir ja selber auch.
Aber auch für unseren Betrieb
bedeutet das einen Spagat
zwischen perfekter Produktion
und Naturschutz.
Es ist nicht sehr einfach.
Nicht einfach, aber die Schwabs
wollten es hier doch versuchen.
Seit zwei Jahren arbeiten sie
mit Birdlife daran,
den vom Aussterben bedrohten Kiebitz
zu retten.
Einige Paare haben sich bereits
im Zuckerrübenfeld
zum Brüten niedergelassen.
Guten Tag, Herr Schwab
- Guten Tag. Freut mich.
Ich bin Francois Turrian,
Geschäftsführer für die Romandie
von Birdlife Schweiz.
Salut! Ich bin Franz. Francois.
Und du?
- Martin.
Martin! Es freut mich.
Sind Sie zufrieden bis jetzt?
- Ja, wir sind sehr zufrieden.
Wir hatten Probleme bei der ersten
Brut, die klappte nicht.
Aber die zweite Brut
war erfolgreich.
Beim Arbeiten auf dem Feld dürfen
die Nester nicht zerstört werden
und die Jungvögel dürfen nicht
mit Pestiziden in Kontakt kommen.
Für die Landwirte
bedeutet das einen Mehraufwand.
Es ist etwas ganz Neues,
seit letztem Jahr.
Ich kannte die Kiebitze
vorher nicht.
Vögel allgemein
kennen wir nicht so gut.
Wir hatten zu wenig
mit diesem Metier zu tun.
Spatzen, Schwalben kennen wir.
Aber Kiebitze kannten wir nicht,
mein Vater und ich.
Ist es für den Betrieb
ein Problem oder eine Chance?
Es ist interessant.
Es ist ein wenig beides. Es ist eine
Chance, und manchmal etwas Aufwand.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen
klappt die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen uns und Stefan ja sehr gut.
Für uns ist es spannend.
Ich habe in den letzten zwei Jahren
so viel über Vögel dazugelernt,
wie ich vorher
in 18 Jahren nicht wusste.
Dank diesen Bemühungen sind
mittlerweile 20 bis 25 Kiebitz-Paare
in die Region zurückgekehrt.
Die Experten,
also die Vogelbeobachter,
wie man so schön sagt,
werden bei uns auch an
eine Bauernversammlung eingeladen.
Das ist ja ein Quantensprung,
nicht wahr.
Das wäre vor 30 Jahren
nicht möglich gewesen.
Man muss zusammenkommen.
Wir leben von der Natur,
mit der Natur.
Der Beobachter verbringt
seine Freizeit in der Natur.
Das ist so.
Heute sind wir doch ziemlich ...
besser.
Läuse?
- Keine Läuse.
Mich beschäftigt, wenn wir die
Verschmutzer der Nation sein sollen.
Wie wenn wir den Naturschutz
komplett ausschalten würden.
Das ist nicht so.
Natürlich wurden
in der Landwirtschaft
mit diesem gewaltigen, schnellen,
vielleicht zu schnellen Fortschritt
Fehler gemacht.
Aber wer hat keine gemacht?
Wo wurden sie nicht gemacht?
Und doch:
Der jahrzehntelange Pestizideinsatz
gilt als einer der Hauptgründe dafür,
dass es immer weniger Insekten gibt.
Eine viel zitierte Studie
aus Deutschland
spricht von einem Rückgang von
über 70 % in den letzten 30 Jahren.
Erschreckend und wahrscheinlich
auch in der Schweiz Realität.
Dominique Bourg ist Philosoph -
spezialisiert auf Ökologie
und nachhaltige Entwicklung.
Man muss sich bewusst sein,
dass das Aussterben von Tierarten
früher sehr langsam verlief und
Hunderttausende von Jahren dauerte.
Nun haben wir es mit einem
viel schnelleren Prozess zu tun.
Wir haben einen starken Rückgang
der Populationen.
Nicht nur bei den Vögeln,
sondern bei allen Wirbeltieren.
Neue Studien zeigen,
dass in den letzten 30 Jahren
57 % der wild lebenden Wirbeltier-
populationen verschwunden sind.
Diese Entwicklung ist beängstigend,
alarmierend.
Das ist keineswegs übertrieben.
So etwas hat es noch nie gegeben
und wir wissen,
dass wir Menschen
dafür verantwortlich sind.
Und in der Schweiz ist es keinesfalls
besser als im Rest der Welt.
Ein Blick in die roten Listen macht
dies deutlich:
79 % der Reptilien,
70 % der Amphibien
und 39 % der Säugetiere
sind in der Schweiz bedroht.
Und auch unsere Pflanzen
und Böden sind unter Druck.
* Elektrisches brummendes Surren *
* Das Surren
geht in ein Alarmsignal über. *
Wir machen hier auf 10 m2
eine umfassende Erhebung von allem,
was wächst.
In der ganze Schweiz
gibt es 1'650 solcher Flächen.
Alain ist einer
von etwa 100 Spezialisten,
die an einem Projekt des Bundesamts
für Umwelt mitarbeiten -
mit dem Ziel, zu beobachten,
wie sich die Biodiversität
in der Schweiz entwickelt.
Er arbeitet hier an einem Waldrand
in der Umgebung von Chavornay.
An einem solchen Standort findet man
normalerweise so etwa 40 Arten.
Es gibt hier Pflanzen,
die an ein Feuchtgebiet erinnern,
aber auch solche, die eher typisch
sind für nährstoffreichere Böden.
Es gibt hier
ein gutes Dutzend Gräserarten,
die man nur anhand kleinster
Unterschiede auseinanderhalten kann.
Ein Blatthäutchen
oder die Behaarung zeigt mir,
dass es sich
um verschiedene Arten handelt.
Das Programm des Bundesamtes
für Umwelt wurde 2001 gestartet.
Es soll zeigen,
wie sich die Pflanzenarten
in unterschiedlichen Lebensräumen
langfristig entwickeln.
Verantwortlich für dieses Projekt
ist Glenn Litsios.
Wer nicht gerade Biologe ist,
meint wohl,
dass rundherum doch alles grün ist -
und das reicht.
Die Pflanzen sind grün, und
solange es um uns herum grün ist,
ist auch die Biodiversität da.
Was wir aber beobachten,
ist eine Verarmung der Lebensräume.
Wir finden immer öfter
überall dieselben Arten.
Z.B.?
Z.B. der Löwenzahn,
eine typische Fettwiesenpflanze,
die Stickstoff und Dünger
im Boden mag.
Weil solche Böden in der Schweiz
immer häufiger werden,
finden wir den Löwenzahn heute
auf praktisch allen unseren
Biodiversitätsmonitoringflächen.
Das Ausmass der Verarmung ist riesig:
Fast die Hälfte der natürlichen
Lebensräume in der Schweiz
sind bedroht. Das hat Auswirkungen
auf die Pflanzen dort.
Und es fragt sich,
ob sie auf Dauer überleben werden.
Wer wissen will, wie es um die
Biodiversität in der Schweiz steht,
muss nur die roten Listen anschauen.
Sie zeigen,
wie stark eine Art bedroht ist.
In der Schweiz stehen dort mehr
Arten als in unseren Nachbarländern.
Insgesamt ist etwa ein Drittel
der untersuchten Arten
mehr oder weniger stark
vom Aussterben bedroht.
Es geht aber nicht nur um die Tiere
oder um ein paar Pflanzen.
Auch wir Menschen sind in jeder
Hinsicht von einer Natur abhängig,
die im Gleichgewicht ist.
Wir sind auf mehreren Ebenen
von der Biodiversität abhängig.
Sie erbringt uns
sog. Ökosystemleistungen.
Das beinhaltet alles aus der Natur,
von dem wir einen Nutzen haben.
Z.B. saubere Luft.
Wir vergessen gerne,
dass unser Sauerstoff
ein Produkt der Photosynthese ist,
die durch Pflanzen geleistet wird
und uns das Atmen ermöglicht.
Es gibt unzählige
Ökosystemleistungen.
Z.B. die Bodenfruchtbarkeit.
Entzieht man einem Boden das Leben,
so wird er unfruchtbar.
Es gibt keine Prozesse
zur Herstellung von Humus
oder Bodenfruchtbarkeit.
Wir brauchen die Biodiversität
für diese Leistungen,
die für das Leben auf der Erde
unabdingbar sind.
Die Schweiz ist sehr gut,
wenn es um Diagnosen geht.
Das Bundesamt für Umwelt
veröffentlicht Berichte,
die zeigen, dass es der Natur
schlecht geht, dass sie leidet
und dass die Listen der bedrohten
Arten immer länger werden.
Der Befund ist also da,
durch die Behörden ermittelt.
Aber es hapert
an den Mitteln für Taten.
Der Bund
stellt nicht genügend Mittel bereit,
um den Biodiversitätsverlust und
den Rückgang der Vögel zu stoppen.
Natur- und Vogelschutz
sind Bestandteil einer nationalen
Biodiversitätsstrategie.
Sie entstand im Jahr 2009.
Es dauerte ganze acht Jahre,
bis aus der Strategie
ein Aktionsplan entstand.
Während der Amtszeit
von Bundesrätin Doris Leuthard.
Ja, wir haben ein Problem, darum
haben wir diese Strategie gewählt,
den Aktionsplan definiert
und das Budget erhöht.
Und jetzt sind wir am Umsetzen.
In zwei, drei Jahren wird man
bestimmt positivere Resultate sehen,
aber das braucht viel Zeit.
Klar, die Situation
ist wirklich alarmierend.
Wir müssen handeln und uns
nicht mit dem zufriedengeben,
was wir jetzt gerade tun.
Aber könnten Sie als Umweltministerin
der Sache nicht
eine höhere Priorität einräumen?
Sie sind doch
schon ein Weilchen im Amt,
das Problem
besteht auch schon länger,
und dennoch
bewegen wir uns im Schneckentempo.
Zugegeben, es hat lange gedauert,
bis aus der Strategie
der Aktionsplan entstanden ist.
Es war schwierig.
Es gingen über 400 Vorschläge ein,
auch seitens der Zivilgesellschaft
und der NGOs.
Das war einfach zu viel.
Zudem ist das Parlament im Sparmodus
und will Umweltausgaben eher kürzen.
Aber ich habe trotzdem
für die kurzfristigen Massnahmen
zusätzliche Mittel bekommen.
Aber es ist immer ein Kampf.
Für die Landwirtschaft
oder das Militär
bekommt man einfacher Geld
als für die Umwelt.
Ebenfalls in der Kritik
stehen die Massnahmen durch den Bund
zur Förderung der Biodiversität
in der Landwirtschaft.
Zu teuer und wenig wirksam.
Die Regeln sind klar:
Die Landwirte erhalten vom Bund
nur dann Direktzahlungen,
wenn sie einen Teil
ihrer Betriebsfläche
zum Schutz der Natur ausscheiden.
Bonjour!
Hier haben wir unsere Ökofläche.
Sie liegt direkt am Waldrand.
Im Frühling eggen wir dieses Land
einmal, um es etwas auszuebnen.
Danach mähen wir
höchstens zwei Mal pro Jahr.
Seit ein paar Jahren
gibt es hier immer mehr Blumen,
die einfach so wachsen, weil wir
gar nichts tun, auch nicht düngen.
Wir lassen die Parzelle
so wie sie ist.
Isabelle Sommer baut hier,
in der Nähe des Murtensees,
auf 45 ha Gemüse an.
Davon bleiben etwa 4 % ungenutzt.
Diese Fläche haben Sie
wegen der Direktzahlungen?
Ja, die Ökofläche ist abhängig
von der Grösse des Betriebs.
Es handelt sich um Parzellen,
die sich nicht unbedingt
für den Anbau von Gemüse
oder Ähnlichem eignen,
weil sie zwischen der Strasse
und dem Wald liegen
und ziemlich klein
und schwierig zu bearbeiten sind.
Und plötzlich
sind Schmetterlinge und Insekten da?
Richtig, Bienen,
Schmetterlinge und andere Insekten.
Sogar Wildschweine,
Rehe, Hasen und Füchse leben hier.
Die Natur ist sehr aktiv.
Wenn wir eine Parzelle
ein paar Jahre lang in Ruhe lassen,
übernimmt die Natur und zeigt uns,
dass sie stärker ist als wir.
Für Massnahmen wie diese zahlt
der Bund jährlich 400 Mio. Fr.
Das sind 14 %
der gesamten Direktzahlungen.
Doch in den über 20 Jahren
seit ihrer Einführung
konnte man damit
den Rückgang der Pflanzen,
Insekten und Vögel nicht stoppen.
Geschweige denn
die Situation verbessern.
Menge und Qualität
der vorgeschriebenen Ökoflächen
reichen nicht aus.
Doch es gibt auch Landwirte,
die bedeutend mehr tun,
als das Gesetz von ihnen verlangt.
Das weiss auch Philippe Roch,
ehemaliger Direktor
des Bundesamts für Umwelt.
Ich finde die Landwirtschaft,
zumindest hier rundherum,
macht Fortschritte. In den 20, 30,
40 Jahren, seit ich hier bin,
ist es besser geworden.
Es gibt noch Bauern, die zu viele
Herbizide einsetzen oder anderes,
aber insgesamt haben wir hier
mehr Natur als vor 40 Jahren
und gewisse Arten
sind zurückgekehrt.
Dank einfacher Massnahmen
wie kleine ungenutzte Wiesenstreifen
sind bedrohte Vogelarten
wieder zum Nisten da,
z.B. das Schwarzkehlchen,
der Orpheusspötter
oder die Dorngrasmücke.
Es funktioniert sehr gut.
Was bisher getan wurde,
ist grossartig,
und wir müssen so weitermachen.
Es gibt nicht bloss
die geschützten Flächen.
Sie sind auch miteinander verbunden,
intelligent verteilt,
da sieht man rasch
einen Fortschritt.
Aber es braucht Zeit und natürlich
bringen alle Massnahmen
auf den Agrarflächen nichts,
wenn nebenan
die halbe Schweiz zubetoniert wird.
Es ist nicht nur die Landwirtschaft,
aber dort gibt es Lösungen und die
Bauern müssen unterstützt werden.
Aber wir müssen auch
dieses Wahnsinnswachstum stoppen.
Philippe Roch
nimmt kein Blatt vor den Mund.
Er kämpft mit Überzeugung
gegen ein Wachstum,
das von der Natur entkoppelt ist.
Dieses Modell funktioniert nicht.
Die Welt hat ihre Grenzen und wir
können nicht immer weiter wachsen.
An ewiges Wachstum zu glauben,
ist eine Illusion.
An einem bestimmten Punkt
ist Schluss.
Es wäre besser, nicht zu warten,
bis die Natur uns stoppt,
weil es kein sauberes Wasser
und nichts mehr zu essen gibt
und wir dann unseren Nachbarn
wegen des letzten Stücks Schinken
umbringen.
Es wäre klug,
ein Leben im Gleichgewicht
mit der Natur anzustreben,
statt mit diesem absurden System
von Wettbewerb und Wachstum
weiterzumachen.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass wir es uns erlauben können,
kein Wachstum anzustreben.
Aber Wachstum
bedeutet nicht nur immer grösser,
bedeutet nicht,
die Schweiz zuzubetonieren.
Wir brauchen qualitatives Wachstum,
nachhaltiges Wachstum.
Nicht nur kurzfristige Effekte,
die der Wirtschaft helfen.
Das ist mir sehr wichtig,
und es kostet viel Zeit.
Da brauchen wir auch
die Unterstützung der Bevölkerung,
die den Politikern sagt:
"Schluss jetzt!"
Anzeichen für ein Umdenken
sind schon heute zu finden.
Aus diesen Einfamilienhäusern,
umgeben von den immer gleichen Gärten
und Rasenflächen,
sticht eines heraus:
Die Gremauds haben es gewagt,
die bürgerliche Ordnung
infrage zu stellen.
Zuerst hatten wir einen Rasen
mit allem Drum und Dran:
Vertikutieren im Frühling
und im Herbst, düngen.
Eines schönen Tages sagte ich mir:
"Nein, das will ich nicht mehr."
Das macht dich ja wahnsinnig:
Wir haben jeweils auf allen Vieren
Gänseblümchen und Klee gejätet,
weil wir glaubten,
sonst würden Bienen angezogen und
die Kinder in die Füsse gestochen.
Aber ich bin ja
mit Bienen aufgewachsen
und wir wurden auch nicht
mehr gestochen als andere Kinder.
Eines Tages beschlossen wir also,
einfach alles wachsen zu lassen.
Wir haben jetzt viele Insekten
und mit ihnen natürlich
alle Insektenfresser.
Meisen nisten bei uns
und es kommen auch immer wieder
Schwalben im Quartier vorbei.
Die Gremauds lieben Schwalben.
Auch in Massen.
Alle 22 Nester sind besetzt.
Und der Kot? Was soll's!
Schwalben haben etwas Mystisches,
Magisches.
Sie kommen von weit her
und finden ihr Zuhause.
Das ist doch fantastisch.
Letztes Jahr haben wir
Solarkollektoren installiert
und dachten, die Schwalben könnten
unser Haus nicht wiederfinden.
Aber nein! Sie sind direkt hierher
zu ihren Nestern geflogen.
Auch Ornithologe Lionel Maumary
kämpft für die Vögel.
Wo er nur kann, setzt er sich ein
für den Erhalt oder
die Neugestaltung von Lebensraum.
Im Vallee de Joux
setzt er sich dafür ein,
dass ein paar Meter Wiese
nicht genutzt werden.
Wir befinden uns am Oberlauf
der Orbe, hier direkt hinter mir.
Auf beiden Seiten des Flusses wird
auf einem 5-10 m breiten Streifen
seit etwa zehn Jahren
nicht mehr gemäht.
Dank dieser Schutzstreifen kann das
Braunkehlchen hier wieder nisten.
Auch Sumpfrohrsänger, Wiesenpieper
und Rohrammern.
Nicht weit entfernt
wird in der Gemeinde Chenit
liebevoll ein Fussgängersteg
unterhalten.
Die Gemeinde
will den Holzsteg schützen
und Eltern mit Kinderwagen
das Durchkommen erleichtern.
So etwas treibt mich die Wände hoch.
Es ist unglaublich.
Natürlich darf man Wege unterhalten,
aber nicht mitten in der Nistzeit,
sondern im September oder Oktober,
wenn die Vögel weg sind.
Wir sind hier
mitten in einem Sumpfgebiet
am Rande einer Naturschutzzone.
Solche Dienste im Sinne
der Ordnung und Bequemlichkeit
haben hier
einfach keine Berechtigung.
Vor einigen Jahrzehnten
wurden die Wiesen
noch im Sommer von Hand gemäht.
Nicht mit der Perfektion von heute.
Da blieben
ein paar ungemähte Stellen zurück
und die reichten schon
als Zufluchtsorte für die Vögel.
Man muss den Vögeln nur
ein kleines bisschen Platz lassen
und nicht noch den letzten
Quadratmeter bewirtschaften.
Früher sagten die Bauern,
sie würden Platz lassen,
damit die Feen tanzen können.
Das fehlt heute.
Ein bisschen mehr Platz.
Würde das schon reichen?
Für die Feldvögel
ist es bereits fünf vor zwölf.
Zur Erinnerung: Bei uns ist
fast die Hälfte der Arten bedroht -
dreimal so viel wie weltweit.
Heute richten wir Schaden an,
mit sehr langfristigem Effekt
und mit irreversiblen Folgen.
Das sollte uns
in höchstem Masse beunruhigen,
hält uns aber kaum vom Schlafen ab.
Aufgepasst:
Ich sage nicht, es sei aussichtslos,
aber nur so etwas nebenbei
reicht nicht.
Wir müssen mit voller Kraft
systematisch handeln.
Unser ganzes System, das sich
über Jahrhunderte entwickelt hat,
ist betroffen. Wir können nicht
einfach die Fassade erneuern.
Wir müssen das Systems im Kern
ändern, und das ist kompliziert.
Wir alle, die unseren Alltag
oft völlig losgelöst verbringen
von der Natur,
die doch unsere Lebensgrundlage ist,
müssten wir also vielleicht nochmals
ganz von vorne anfangen?
Uns die Zeit nehmen und uns
in einem der wenigen Naturschutz-
gebiete umsehen und lernen.
Heute früh habe ich
einen Trauerschnäpper gesehen,
dem das Verschwinden der Insekten
sehr schadet.
Auch einen Buntspecht,
ein Goldhähnchen
und einen Schwarzen Milan.
Gehört habe ich insgesamt
rund 30 Vogelarten.
Um einer solchen Vielfalt
zu begegnen,
muss man in ein Gebiet gehen,
das so vielfältig und reich ist
wie dieses hier.
Diesen Ort oberhalb von Vevey be-
halten die Vogelbeobachter für sich,
ähnlich wie es Pilzsammler tun.
In den frühen Morgenstunden
taucht Jacques Pitteloud
in unsere Schweizer Vogelwelt ein,
die schöner, farbiger
und für uns lebenswichtiger ist
als wir es uns vorstellen können.
Der Distelfink
ist ein kleines Schmuckstück,
ein Juwel mit spektakulären Farben.
Er ist durch die Umweltveränderungen
stark zurück gegangen.
Es ist immer ein Vergnügen,
seinen Gesang im Flug zu hören,
der so typisch ist. Wunderschön.
* Zartes Zirpen *
Stellen Sie sich einen Frühling vor
ohne Vogelgesang,
ausser ein paar Krähen und Elstern.
Stellen Sie sich eine Welt vor,
in der alle diese Farben,
Formen und Variationen
verschwunden sind für den Profit
von ein paar schmarotzerischen Arten
wie der unseren.
Eine Welt ohne Natur wäre
eine sehr traurige, düstere Welt.
Eine Welt ohne Poesie. Und eine Welt
ohne Poesie, die ist nicht schön.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Lilian Zbinden - 2019